aujourd'hui que macro m'entende je dis
merde à monsieur l'allemand les mecs me
court après pour m'arrêter en disant
monsieur rodrigues
s'il vous plaît contrôle d'identité ils
savent qui je suis
ils savent qui je suis ils viennent me
contrôler soi-disant de cette rue là là
avenue de tourville là où ils m'ont
arrêté et dans un truc interdite ce
n'est nullement stipulé dans l'arrêté
ils ont uni une amende à un endroit où
j'ai le droit de me balader tout
simplement donc aujourd'hui monsieur
l'allemange vous regarde droit dans les
yeux je vous dis merde vous avez détruit
ma vie
vous avez détruit ma vue vous avez ruiné
vous pouvez faire ce que vous voulez me
mettre en prison je suis un [ __ ]
d'opposants politiques et je vous
emmerde et toute votre vie et je vous le
dis mon gant et je vous le dis vous
serez jamais accompagné tout le temps de
300 policiers et un jour ou l'autre vous
aurez en face de moi
il vous croiserait le regard que vous
avez multi les c'est tout
[Applaudissements]